what did you think when you first saw
this the whole thing yes I was
gobsmacked yeah I really was I mean III
more as a willing audience I try and
forget what I think I know and I was
really surprised
delighted moved I thought here's what I
love the quiet build the way that sound
just goes away I love that the restraint
the look how long it takes to get into
the collage of the bombing because
that's so not what this is for you know
it's not Tommy Goren stuff it's it and
then when it comes it's just like ah
excuse my French four letter word delete
is appropriate you know and play the
playing at this love story which I mean
falling in love is one thing but having
all the other emotion that these two
people went through what was it like for
you as an actor and as a person at the
end of the day having to go through that
always I mean it's it's it's a weird
thing to say but there is an immense
amount of joy that goes along with
getting to do this kind of work you know
getting to play with actors like Miranda
and Jake who are so completely committed
and such incredible characters you know
who cover all of these amazing emotional
depths and nuances I mean for me it was
a total joy as much as it it's difficult
and you are mining things that are
painful we're very lucky to get to you
know walk in people's shoes and and sort
of understand and empathize and these
characters are so fascinating and you
know so that it was it was like an
immersive thing you know we were filming
in Boston and I don't think any of us
really popped out of it or yeah and I'm
sure you see you're not past the point
now of where you learned something about
yourself after doing a role but after
doing a role like this what did you
learn about yourself I guess just the
the I don't know just the question it's
more of a question I think that that I
was posing was what would I do
how would I how would I survive this how
would I cope could I stick around could
I could I see this through or would I
leave you know like all those ideas
notions of of self-preservation and and
you don't need to protect yourself and
all of that comes up so I think it was
more questions and we we know that Jeff
and Erin are not together anymore but do
you know it has she seen the movie do
you know if she saw it and how she felt
about it I don't know I mean I think
yeah yeah
yeah I don't know at what point um but
uh ya know I think it was good because I
think they were sitting behind David
when they show them read them all
together yeah yeah and where were you
guys I don't even know when you shot
this week was it a long time ago was it
I was it every it was last year ago and
and cuz watching this we all have a
memory of what that day was where it was
you know a police chase and a manhunt
and at this into this and it is when did
it hit you that people who went through
it didn't actually see that event that
way that it was something completely
different
to somebody like Jeff I thought well I
mean I I was there at the marathon this
year it was worst year well yeah when
Erin crossed the finish line in and
connected with Jeff and I guess guess
for me it was just seeing I mean
throughout the process you you come to
terms with the fact that this isn't
about the headlines it's about the
people affected and individual
experiences and families who are forever
changed but watching people cross the
finish line I was like oh right this is
where it was and these are the
individual bodies crossing this finish
line the people who are there cheering
them on who all have a stake in this and
I think we can get really confused and
bewildered by numbers and headlines and
kind of buzzwords but this movies not
about that it's really about individual
people and continuance hmm well thank
you guys so much